it's Mr Beast versus Mr Beast Burger yes
Mr Beast the YouTuber extraordinaire is
suing virtual dining Concepts the
company behind the ghost kitchen Mr
Burger franchise alleging that the
hamburgers are so bad it's a breach of
contract uh now I checked out the
reviews and uh they're not great
that's just disgusting the meat has like
a weird
it's like sausage this tick tocker says
the Buns look like hockey pucks look at
the bottom of my buns like all my
sandwiches were like this it's a
freaking hockey puck honestly in my
experience Mr Beast Burger has been
perfectly acceptable but uh you know Mr
Beast is gonna have a Target on his back
Mr Beast whose real name is Jimmy
Donaldson wants a court to stop the
company from selling the burger
offerings using the Mr Beast name but
virtual dining Concepts has countersuit
asserting that Donaldson and Beast
Investments tried to sabotage the
company because it refused to sell him a
burger steak yes I guess you could say
they've got beef oh where's the beef now
the Mr Beast complaint opens with a bit
of extra mustard okay I promise that's
the last food pun Donaldson touts his
almost 200 million YouTube subscribers
and Compares himself to Joe DiMaggio
when Joe DiMaggio was asked why he
hustled on every play of every game he
responded that there's always a kid who
may be seeing me for the first time I
owe him my best and now is probably a
good time to remind you that a complaint
is a one-sided legal document with
unproven allegations that's partially
about starting a lawsuit but also it's
about PR as well and uh Jimmy's lawyers
are definitely taking Liberty with this
one but to be fair if I had 200 million
subscribers you'd probably hear me
talking about it as well so feel free to
uh smash that to like And subscribe
buttons but anyway Mr B's contracted
with virtual dining Concepts in March of
2020 to launch and run a virtual dining
brand called Mr Beast Burger the
business would create a virtual
restaurant with a selection of Mr Beast
branded food items but would then
partner with existing restaurants who
would prepare those items and share in
significant portion of the revenue from
their sales by 2021 VDC had opened over
1700 virtual locations but it received
some mixed reviews some to write it as
disgusting revolting and inedible some
customers said they were shocked
Donaldson would be involved in such a
subpar product for example this Reddit
post claims that a Mr Beast Burger was
mostly just raw meat which you can see
in the photograph and the complaint
points out that more than half of the Mr
Beast Burger virtual restaurants have
less than two out of 5 Stars which is
well below the median score of four
stars across the platform and Donaldson
says he attended regular weekly or
bi-weekly meetings with BDC in an
attempt to address the quality control
issues but VDC didn't do enough to
address the concerns according to Jimmy
virtual dining Concepts was more focused
on developing similar products with
quote other celebrities for its own
benefit to do quality control on Mr
Beast burger and there are other
allegations of EDC was overly committed
to Global expansion of Mr Beast Burger
instead of quality control now
apparently despite these problems on
January 23 2022 Jimmy went ahead and
contracted with VDC to open brick and
mortar locations and they signed a
second contract the parties opened one
brick and mortar store in New Jersey at
the American dream mall and it was an
instant hit over ten thousand people
swarmed the restaurant on opening day
thank you
and in fact Collins and Samir did an
entire documentary about the opening of
this particular location but Mr B says
that virtual dining Concepts dragged its
feet on opening more restaurants because
over 90 percent of its Revenue was
coming from the virtual business so
here's part of the issue on the one hand
Mr B says that vdc's management of Mr
Beast Burger was a train wreck and on
the other hand he was eager to expand
their agreement into brick and mortar
businesses and his argument is that if
he doubled down on the business
relationship he and his people would
finally be able to fix all those
problems however we don't have the
contract in front of us so we don't
actually know if it gave him control or
influence over the food quality that's
right it's contract law
[Applause]
or I guess more specifically it all
depends on what's actually written in
the contract itself but the complaint
says that the parties entered into an
endorsement agreement that gave EDC the
right to utilize Mr beast's name images
likeness voice picture and photograph
signature biographical data endorsements
and statements to Market and promote the
brand however Mr Beast pertained all of
his own intellectual property rights and
it gave him the right to approve all
uses of his image and likeness and the
approval must be in writing and Mr B
says that VDC registered trademarks for
Mr Beast Burger in the European Union
Canada Thailand Singapore Mexico and
Malaysia without his prior written
approval the trademarks were registered
solely in vdc's name and Mr B says he's
never made any money from this
particular deal now Mr Beast and Beast
Investments asked the court for a
declaratory judgment that would allow
them to terminate the entirety of the Mr
Beast Burger business they say that the
second agreement which he signed to
expand the business into brick and
mortar gives him the right to terminate
the contract if quote Mr Beast burger
materially and irreparably tarnishes Mr
BEAST's reputation the complaint says
that virtual dining Concepts failed to
quote create a jointly owned entity with
plaintiff for the brick and mortar side
of the business that had failed to let
Donaldson appoint a manager of the
business and it failed to transfer
shares of virtual dining Concepts
Holdings Inc to Beast Investments as
required by the agreement and Mr B's
second cause of action is for a material
breach of the endorsement agreement he
argues that virtual dining Concepts
tarnish the Mr Beast brand now tarnished
is a technical term for trademark law
but it says it tarnish the brand by
filing at least six International
trademark registrations without prior
approval creating and disseminating
advertising and marketing materials that
feature the brand attributes without
getting Mr Beast approval failing to pay
Donaldson and consistently serving
inedible food and providing incompetent
service the third and final cause of
action is for full accounting of the
business's profits inequitable
accounting is a demand that the other
party turn over the books for inspection
the plaintiffs want VDC to prepare
detailed schedules and income and
expenses over a defined period determine
how much money the BDC company owns now
Mr Beast and Beast Investments are
asking for a jury trial royalties and
the right to terminate the contract and
they want VDC to immediately stop using
the Mr Beast brand now Mr B seems to
have some really good lawyers but if you
want a great lawyer my firm the eagle
team can help if you've been in a car
crash dealt with sexual harassment or
suffered from cancer we can represent
you or help find you the right attorney
just click on the link in the
description for a free consultation with
my team the museums just need a legal
team you need the eagle team the links
below now unsurprisingly virtual dining
concept sees things differently they
countersued Mr Beast and Beast Ventures
for breach of contract quote this case
is about a social media celebrity who
believes his Fame means that his word
does not matter that the facts do not
matter and that he can reneg and breach
his contractual obligations without
consequence and virtual dining Concepts
contends that when they contracted with
Donaldson the parties agree that Mr
Beast would quote become the face of a
virtual restaurant brand in exchange for
a share of the revenue and later a stake
in the business BDC says that Donaldson
was the one who pushed the rapid
expansion of Beast Burger quote while
plaintiffs originally planned to open Mr
Beast Burger in a smaller select number
of locations defendants pushed
plaintiffs to open Mr Beast Burger in as
many locations as possible BDC downplays
the negative reviews saying that
customer reviews of Mr Beast Burger met
or exceeded industry averages and that
the brand was overwhelmingly well
received by the media the general public
and customers alike by way of brief
illustration only in 2022 of the 2
million orders placed on doordash and
ubereats alone almost 70 percent of the
customer reviews included 5 star ratings
and in 2023 almost half of Mr Beast
Burger customers are returning customers
BTC says the actual complaints were
relatively few in number compared to the
overall number of burgers sold so if the
reviews weren't that bad then why would
Mr B start attacking Mr beastburger on
social media accounts well VDC claims
that behind the scenes Donaldson was
trying to quote pressure them to sell
all or a material portion of Mr Beast
Burger to him by using his massive
online presence to sabotage the brand
and plaintiff's business one tweet
implied that Jimmy was quitting Mr Beast
Burger quote I started Mr Beast Burger
to help restaurants make more money
during the pandemic and it worked but
sadly when working with 2 000
restaurants I don't own it's impossible
to guarantee order quality I'm moving on
for Mr Beast Burger so I can focus on
feastables and making snacks now Jimmy
deleted that tweet but the media ran
story after Story stating that the brand
was closing down VDC says that Donaldson
and his licensing company quote scheme
to exploit their leverage and reneg on
their agreements in an effort to seek a
better more lucrative deal now VDC
claims that the negative comments
material damage the business and its
partner restaurants quote Donaldson's
baseless and unlawful disparagement had
the intended effect Mr Beast Burger's
reputation was materially damaged if not
destroyed customers abandoned the brand
in plaintiff's hard-won relationships
vendors partners and suppliers were
shattered causing damages to plaintiff's
thought according to the evidence in
Donaldson's own statements regarding the
value of Mr Beast Burger are in the nine
figure range sadly Donaldson's conduct
has also damaged the bottom lines of
hundreds of restaurants across the
country and around the world BDC doesn't
deny making the trademark applications
but it claims that it was consistent
with endorsement agreement and the
company alleges that under the
agreement's terms the intellectual
property developed for the brand would
be jointly owned by Donaldson and VDC
the company says that they always plan
to assign the trademarks to the party's
jointly owned company but Donaldson
quote blocked the necessary corporate
paperwork to create the company now as
for Mr B's claim that he hasn't shared
in the profits of Mr Beast Burger PDC
says it transferred the shares into his
account on March 28 2022. BDC says that
Beast Investments tried to obtain a
larger share of the brand with proposals
in November 2022 February 2023 and June
2023 but VDC apparently rejected all
proposals as unreasonable and
unacceptable the company claims that
these rejections prompted Beast
Investments and Donaldson to turn on the
brand quote frustrated by their
inability to extract a new deal more
favorable to defense on March 30th 2023
defendants Council sent a letter to
plaintiffs fabricating several alleged
breaches of the agreement so vdc's first
cause of action is for breach of
contract and argues that Jimmy failed to
make personal appearances refused to
attend important production sessions to
make marketing materials fail to promote
the brand on social media purposefully
made untruthful and misleading
statements denied the company access to
the Brand's social media accounts and
disparage the Brand's products and
services BDC also claims that Donaldson
failed to form the jointly owned company
for the brick and mortar business that
he failed to promote it and that he
failed to use good faith commercially
reasonable efforts to negotiate and
finalize the transaction documents and
VDC says that Donaldson violated the
non-compete non-solicitation provision
of the agreement by quote enticing away
persuading and or attempting to persuade
clients customer suppliers marketing
partners and other vendors to
discontinue their relationship with VDC
and go elsewhere BDC also claims that Mr
Beast breached the Covenant of good
faith and fair dealing and engaged in
tortious interference with contractual
relations by making media posts that
were intended to tarnish the Beast
Burger brand so with that out of the way
let's get to the meat of this matter I
lied there are a lot more puns coming
now each party in a contract is
responsible for fulfilling its
obligations under the contract when a
party fails to perform its obligations
on her contract this is called a breach
of contract and there are entire classes
on this in law school but generally
speaking to terminated contract the
breach of the contract has to be
material to that contract itself and
here one of the most interesting issues
is whether bad reviews tarnishing a
brand and potentially a lack of quality
control can be considered a material
breach Mr B says that vdc's main
obligation under the contract was to
serve decent enough food and that it
breached this condition by serving
terrible food which doesn't look good
for him and all the rest of his Brands
bdc's counter argument is that the
company factually did not serve terrible
food wow
so you've got beautiful smash patties
and it claims that the Mr Beast Burger
ghost kitchens were a massive success
that resulted in 1700 participating
locations BTC argues that this is a
better metric for judging performance
than some random bad reviews from
customers and the company also argues
that even if the food was substandard
that that wasn't a material breach
especially since quality control is
difficult when they're dealing with more
than a thousand individual restaurants
now adding complication these cases were
filed in New York where state law
implies a covenant of good faith and
fair dealing in every contract and under
this contract neither party to a
contract can do anything which has the
effect of destroying or injuring the
right of the other party to receive the
fruits of the contract and here Mr Beast
is effectively arguing that serving
inedible food obviously violates the
Covenant of good faith and fair dealing
will test your meat if it contains human
flesh anything above the four percent
allowable by the FDA then your
restaurant will be closed well VDC is
arguing that trying to torpedo the
relationship through social media is
also a breach of the Covenant of good
faith
now unfortunately we don't have the two
contracts at issue here so we can't
evaluate whether food quality would be
considered a material breach and neither
the complaint or the counter suit cites
the contractual language about whether
damage to reputation would be a material
breach now almost always when you're
talking about a breach of contract if
you're talking about damages you're
talking about money someone breaches a
contract you might be entitled to the
monetary value of the damage that
they've caused and here proving damages
might be challenging for Mr Beast
because so far of the only damages that
are outlined are reputational but if it
really is the case that VDC was doing a
terrible job and not providing any
quality control and really focused on
the high margin ghost Kitchen business
at the expense of building out the brick
and mortar business you can understand
why terminating the contract and
allowing Mr Beast to form a relationship
with some other restaurant proprietor
who can do quality control and can
actually open brick and mortar stores
would be a huge win and on the other
other hand if VDC is correct that it's
not a breach of contract to serve
terrible food and not have quality
control over all the different ghost
kitchens and it was in fact improper for
Mr Beast to try to terminate the
contract itself then they would be
probably entitled to whatever the value
of that contract was in terms of its
profits over a reasonable period of time
and VDC is suing for 100 million dollars
which as long time legal eaglets no it's
just a made-up number that will have to
be verified with actual data because you
can make up whatever damages you want in
your complaint or your counter suit so
we don't know how this litigation will
play out either factually or legally we
don't have all the facts and we don't
have all the law in terms of the
contract that binds the parties here
both sides could have legitimate
arguments if nothing else this is a
cautionary tale for any creators out
there who want to start their own
businesses you kind of need to control
the quality of the product that's being
put out there otherwise it could hurt
your brand now even if Mr Beast Burger
burgers are terrible you can still enjoy
a delicious home-cooked meal which is
easy easier than ever with today's
sponsor hellofresh because with
hellofresh you can make it exactly how
you want it whether you want it like a
Mr Beast burger or something else
entirely because a busy fall schedule
doesn't always leave you with time to
spare with hello fresh you don't need to
spend all evening in the kitchen to whip
up a wholesome meal because with
hellofresh's quick easy recipes and 15
minute meals you can simply choose your
recipes and pick your delivery date and
then relax knowing that dinner is
covered because hellofresh keeps your
taste buds on their toes with 40 Chef
crafted recipes to select from every
week from family friendly to fit and
wholesome you always find new and
exciting recipes to try and love hello
fresh is a great way to eat delicious
fresh food while still being healthy now
I'm a do yourself person and I have to
say I was initially pretty skeptical
about hellofresh I'm a pretty good cook
so I didn't think that I needed the help
but I actually loved it even for an
experienced cook hello fresh delivers
new ingredients of recipes that I'd
never try on my own and of course
everything was delivered straight to my
door so I didn't have to do any shopping
the produce actually gets to you faster
than a grocery store so it arrives at
Peak freshness and flavor and it's also
super easy to save time hellofresh cuts
out the meal playing in prep so the
recipes only take 20 to 30 is to cook
literally less time to cook than it'll
normally take for me to do the shopping
and hellofresh is at least 25 cheaper
than takeout so if you'd like to try
hellofresh go to hellofresh.com and use
the code 50 legal eagle at checkout for
50 off plus free shipping yes you can
actually get 50 off plus free shipping
by clicking on the link that's on screen
or down in the description so click on
the link below and use the code 50 legal
eagle at checkout after that click on
this link over here for more illegal
eagle or I'll see you in court